jung
was always fascinated by
the idea that in the psyche
the archetypal self uh
was was a crystalline
structure he had a sense and an
intuition
that that within the psyche
there's a diamond what you may have
heard talked about is the diamond body
and if you look at his uh
collected works volume 9 2
you will see jung's reflections
about some ancient uh images
of of what he believed
contained uh co some some suggestions
intimations insights into the structure
of the self
and so the the title of this essay
in volume nine is the structure and
dynamics of the self
so now the reason i'm sharing this with
you tonight
is because jung
was very fascinated with
the especially earlier in his work with
the
with the the idea
that you can study the collective
unconscious
this is another thing uh that
differentiates
uh jung from uh from
most contemporary uh psychologists
and psychological theories the idea that
there is a collective unconscious
in the codes of the psyche
in any case carl jung was fascinated
he realized from his studies comparative
studies
of world mythology and i recommend that
you look at the index
to volume 20 of the collected works to
see the enormity
of the studies that he did
uh on if you look at this this uh
if you look at this uh
this quadration here there's a there's a
square at the center here there's a
four-sidedness
there's four sides to this to this image
this is an octahedron
and so what we need to remember that
that jung was convinced that in psychic
geography there was a
there was a four square aspect to
psychic geography
and he began his studies being
fascinated
by what he called the quaternio
and the double quaternio
which is the eightfold uh image the four
fold and the eightfold
and i'm sure that that what fascinated
him so much about this
is because i'm
is that this image contains
both um a geometrical representation of
the four fullness there are four sides
to an octahedron if you
if you just
uh turn it in your hand get a calcium
fluorite crystal
hold it turn it in your hands there's
it's it's like a
two space to base but there are only
four
faces on an octahedron four
faces that extend from from top to
bottom
so there's there is an eight-fold
the double quaternio
and there's the four-foldness of the
the four sides of the four faces of an
octahedron
and in that image that single image
jung was intuiting something about this
archetypal code of the structure and
dynamics of the self
now if you look at this section in
in volume 9
you and read this jung was trying to
assign
uh terms for the facets what
he was fast he he was interested in okay
if this is
if this is an image of the structure of
the self what are the facets what are
the sides
what do they represent and what he was
trying to do was to look in
as young taught us to do to look into
mythic traditions
to see what
they might have to tell us about the
deep structures
of the self and so
this was uh this was uh from a
particular tradition some of the gnostic
uh gnostic traditions
and he was trying to associate he would
take these terms
uh moses's carnal man the lower jethro
the negative miriam and so forth and he
was trying to assign the
the the the sort of mythic images of
different personalities and different
qualities
to the octahedron to try to get a sense
of
of what they might mean by looking at
the mythic
uh context now after a while
jung lost interest
in this he he he never
gave up the idea that there was a kind
of a crystalline code
uh uh within the self that the self
that there's a certain uh structure
in the collective unconscious so uh
uh as you know when he tired of this he
began to get more and more interested
uh in the uh in
in the fourth fullness of the psyche and
began to focus on
uh the uh psychological typology
intuition thinking sensation and feeling
and he began to to work a great deal
with uh with with psychological typology
is the forefulness of the psyche trying
to
look at the forefulness and typology
that he came up with
as a way of thinking about what is what
is
the quadration of the psyche about
now his
protege and
lover tony wolf
had another idea about what
the fourfold quadration of the psyche
is and she published this article
in the students association publication
of the young institute
called the structural forms of the
feminine psyche
and she began to say and this
anticipated some of my
later work uh uh
i realized that tony wolf is one of my
uh
my forerunners in jungian psychology and
i
i can if i trace my heritage back to her
in a sense in that she began to look at
there being structural forms other than
typhology other than psychological
typology
and she was focusing on the female
psyche
saying that there is an underlying
structure in the female psyche
now what we'll see in